sorgente un'area della superficie
terrestre dove viene alla luce una
piccola quantità di acqua sorgente però
in senso figurato significa anche
cercare l'origine di qualcosa partire da
essa per andare a fondo e scoprirsi
sorgenti e inizi che dà una possibilità
di crescita in questo momento
particolare mi piace ricordare un
incipit di un racconto di un'autrice
ungherese naturalizzata svizzera parte
da un punto di vista di una bambina che
dice cominciò con una frase una
qualsiasi e il resto si collega da sé i
personaggi appaiono muoiono un po
scompaiono ci sono i buoni e cattivi i
poveri ricchi i vincitori di t
è una cosa che non finisce mai e poi e
poi capita queste della vita di tutti i
giorni
siamo sommersi dalle domande i dubbi
abbiamo poche risposte del restante
diventiamo adulti e andiamo in maniera
appunto frettolosa andiamo prendiamo i
mezzi andiamo al lavoro
incontriamo amici vicini e amici lontani
dobbiamo trovare sempre in modo giusto
per esprimere il nostro sguardo il
nostro punto di vista e cosa meglio di
suoni articolati e complessi che formano
le parole le parole sono comunicazioni
ovvero mettere assieme sono espressioni
orali scritte o la rappresentazione
appunto di un'idea le parole ci
costituiscono fin da quando siamo
piccoli da quando itama dire le prime
parole da mamma fino adesso li
utilizzano in maniera
rosa o alle volte prese troppo sul serio
ma appunto le opinioni le opinioni sono
concetti che rimangono ancora
all'interno fino a che non abbiamo il
coraggio di esporci e raccontare ad alta
voce
ed allora si chiama espressioni cosa
cambia quindi il nostro pensiero non
esiste solo un pensiero sicuro fitto
della terraferma
un pensiero chiaro che cerca di
categorizzare le cause di dimostrarle in
modo oggettivo ma bensì anche un
pensiero narrativo che scorre che
fruisce e che trasmette pensiamo ad
avere un taccuino in mano il nostro
libro preferito c'è un'immagine di
solito il titolo e sorge trasmette già
qualcosa
l'idea che vogliamo dare della nostra
rappresentazione delle generali e valore
generale delle intenzioni e delle
emozioni deve dare senso e per questo
che è il primo passo per rappresentare
le idee le idee che coinvolgono e
trasmettono non solo all'interno della
nostra nel nostro piccolo cerchio a
livello individuale personale ma anche
facendo parte di un gruppo alle volte e
quindi con un in sé un senso soprattutto
di identità sociali
gruppo di una comunità che può essere
sia in sia di un luogo fisico che in un
luogo virtuale si parla oggi forse di
community e quindi un insieme di persone
localizzate appunto come qualche
affinità personale individuale che
cercano di mettere insieme qualcosa che
determina attività di scambio di
contenuti fra i membri community ne
esistono di vario tipo comuni tv
community di interesse community di
apprendimento community anche di
innovazione e qui ci soffermiamo perché
nelle commenti di innovazioni due sono i
veri fattori trasformativi sono la
connessione e la conversazione possiamo
intendere da una community di
innovazione soprattutto la sua
potenzialità data da movimento sociale
che si crea che le singole dotazioni di
saperi di ciascun individuo emergono
come come dei bagagli di esperienze di
condivisione è importante perché a dello
stesso modo ognuno ha la facoltà di
emergere e di potere dare un valore
aggiunto allo stesso gruppo formato
questa immagine ripercorre un po quello
che stiamo vivendo adesso siamo però
l'anno scorso a maggio 2016 e mi trovavo
a exposanità a bologna sul retro della
disciolta di open vaglio medical
iniziative sono risposti tre pilastri
tre parole
la chiave di questa community di
innovazione che altro non sono che il
low cost i freddi printable e l'open
source open mario maj di carini vuole
dare la possibilità punti a tutti i
membri appartenenti all'interno e
all'esterno la possibilità appunto di
contribuire attraverso la realizzazione
di tre prototipi biomedicali e la loro
realizzazione appunto al sì in quel caso
si faceva appunto si dialoga va e si
pensava non ha le potenzialità di una
community stessa e anche di percorsi
appunto da intraprendere in nove e delle
facoltà anche da migliorare come la
personalizzazione realtà dalla stampa 3d
la possibilità che la stampa 3d e poi
dal funzionamento vero e proprio di tre
prototipi di tre prototipi biomedicali
tra cui due ausili per la salute è un
incubatrice neonatale è una sorta di
community sono tante di incontro
possiamo dire agli sotto il ponte scorre
l'acqua londra quale tornerà il discorso
è un incontro tra la parte più formale e
la parte più informale all'interno della
community
c'è la parte informale è formata da il
gruppo del lavoro vero e proprio gli
addetti ai lavori quali sono ingegneri
elettronici ingegneri meccanici designer
distesa comunicazioni e la parte invece
informale che non ha un'accezione
negativa o dispregiativa no a una
gestione di collante perché è fanta di
rapporti umani che sono alla base della
nostra comunicazione
quindi se prendiamo il libro che avevamo
con la copertina con il pensiero
narrativo
se riusciamo ad aprirlo allora si vedono
quattro parole il libro capita anche a
voi di sfogliarlo in libreria o dovunque
siate e libro su scritte le parole che
formano dei periodi che formano di
paragrafi o formano anche dei capitoli
ogni capitolo è fatto dalla mano di
qualcuno in questo caso è data dalla
collaborazione di più membri di più
persone che pongono appunto il loro
aiuto a per migliorare l'innovazione è
anche condivisione perché un forum sarà
il luogo prediletto il rogo scienza per
discutere e per discutere e migliorare
le tecnologie previste e anche per
dialogare è il punto d'incontro si può
dire perché si sorpassano appunto le
scuole sfide giornaliere quelle sfide
che possono essere sorpassato solo con
l'aiuto
di qualcun altro è una possibilità che
ci dà l'occasione appunto di superarle è
fatta anche da domande e le risposte
perché se problema anche questa è una
prova molto importante non ha una
valenza negativa soprattutto al giorno
d'oggi
noi intendiamo così ha una valenza
negativa al problema in questo caso era
la sua etimologia ci ricorda di
questione proposta una questione
proposta con iva per una questione in
cui ci si mette in gioco se alla pole
opportunità di condividere e collaborare
quindi qualcuno magari al di là
dell'oceano abbracciarci al passato il
problema che sto vivendo in questo
momento io e quindi può essere
un'occasione per migliorare
noi siamo alla conclusione bensì a una
continuazione perché se siamo partiti da
sorgenti dei vizi che danno possibilità
di crescita
allora avremo voci conseguenze che danno
opportunità di azione di ricerca e di
conoscenza ad un certo momento le idee
ti coinvolgono intrapreso in questo in
questa in questo gioco quasi strano in
cui la narrazione incontra l'innovazione
e viceversa
e allora le parole ci identificano e ci
comprendono ho cercato in cui il fiume
sbocca nel mare l'ingresso al porto è il
flusso partito era una piccola fessura
posta in alto sulla montagna
condizioni tudine e sceglie poco a poco
a valle incontra i torrenti di contrà
riale ruscelli trasportandosi poi
prendere per prendere forma nel fiume
il fiume il caso vuole ai suoi lati
scorre la vita spera la vita di tutti i
giorni scorrono anche le idee punti
quindi di vista punti di con punti
d'appoggio guardare sempre in
prospettiva in modo alternativo in modo
creativo e in modo soprattutto ambizioso
el'importanza quindi di guardare oltre
di andare un po più in là dove le parole
diventano importanti per ognuno di noi
grazie